what's up
Thank You voiceover Pete for sending me
your sword I will take great care of
this epic sword my ceiling is not very
tall but I do feel very happy
welcome to you laughs you lose everyone
hope you are having a fantastic day
hope you're having smiles and good lamps
and if not you're about to can I just do
this and then do the video the rule is
simple you laugh you lose it's a brand
new show we're testing it out aging
vader face but let's just see how we go
let's jump into it guys hashtag
relatable smash like subscribe on this
video dudes be scared Timon I be happy
in my girl ear like so far very good
scratch that oh it's more Tyler memes
hell yeah spider-man with venom
it's all these live streams like this I
never seen anything beyond these click
this is only dust why what's the context
how are they still making more of these
American soldier did you hear something
tree I'm so glad I'm so glad people can
still make this horrific dump as jokes
like if I made these jokes I would get
in so much trouble
oh-oh-oh
ksi looks like you have a rival here I'm
not deflecting my hairline is fine okay
my hairline is fine
[Music]
I've seen this what an absolute alpha my
god I feel my testosterone levels
increasing just by watching that can we
pull you see it again that was glorious
I want I won't lie this is definitely me
taking a big piece P I mean P nothing I
don't
Oh God this is pretty good shot that
Scott up so far I'm having a good scrap
that that means I have to refill my G
fuel in the meantime maybe you can check
out zero def merch it's available now
and I think you'll like it
what if I tell you keep telling I have
wireless microphone so I can tell you
more about it it's the 90 million club
merch and it's very good much
[Music]
versus my fifth one today just need to
block after me
the pain of being
[Music]
what's up guys I'm back with more G fuel
how's it going over here brauch did you
buy the marked oh why why did it have a
bunch of computers next to a kid
basketball thingy dummies you're a dumb
ball you're a dumb bay you're dumb your
name what are you gonna do
[Music]
goddamn that's go well it happens to the
best of us you know what you don't have
to add a minecraft name to a hooli
everything it just a hey Marty McFly
Williams into Kabul I made uh Scott are
you okay I don't know what's wrong with
my cat why does he look like that it's
funny because it's not a cat it's a
dolphin lol Wow I don't know if I can
laugh at this if it's fake it's not
funny if it's really really funny cuz
then I imagine that they just keep
flying away in maybe lions or save the
animal sounds with Tyler Bonnie's back
the dog goes the cow goes
ah damn I hope it was more oh well so
the only two redeeming qualities Tyler
won means oh come on what stop with the
reign of Felix Arvid oath shall break
through all the change in controversy
you've been by my side there's no army
in the world I would rather give me a
watch time it's been a while right
so while I can still be hurling a -
breakfast from the number one in the
world someone punching the screen No
[Music]
do that the damage
damn so many people liked it I'm so glad
these kid these AG kids that I call them
kids really alright let's watch some
more funny clips what in the world is
stage the baby is my it you save the
baby
people keep saying like my channel is
having bad influence on kids but now 90
million kids yes your old children has
learned how to save a bed bed so you're
welcome
I think my point has been proven and if
you want to show other people how to
save a bad bad 0 def merch you can also
have this also we have the merch coming
up soon I know how to save a bear bear
if it's dying I've been watching so many
cliffs that this guy I I'm thinking
about making a video on it cuz it's so
funny
I mean you've probably seen these before
my favorite one is the most relatable
line of the entire universe I love it so
much it makes me so happy
what are they drinking there's there's
some like this is me when my girlfriend
bla bla bla ha ha ha a joke I just can't
be bothered anymore yes the classic
t-rex pale innocent Triceratops
hi
brontosaurus Oh micro pachycephalosaurs
Oh God what damn what da well what about
oh wait it's coming into the tour okay
where does it get its top oh it keeps
going that was they really all right
that's it for this week's you laugh you
lose if you had a fun time today a great
way to support the channel is by merch
and I'll see you guys tomorrow and have
a great time until then goodbye and
watch like other youtubers as well it it
is okay anyone else this is you tubers
simulator it's now so relevant that it's
got a brand new minigame crania drop the
crane and get fresh items only available
in the washing machine like game and you
say there's more of course there is new
knowledge perks new quests and new pics
links and legs guys lake